ces images prises à la dérobée dans la
région de xinjiang montre l'extérieur
des fameux camp d'internement que veut
cacher la chine
les rares journalistes étrangers qui
arrivent à s'en approcher sont
rapidement intercepté officiellement la
chine dit qu'il s'agit de centres
d'apprentissage et de formation
professionnelle ou se rendre
volontairement de jeunes musulmans qui
auraient commis des fautes mineures mais
la fuite de documents secrets du
gouvernement chinois obtenu par le
consortium international des
journalistes d' enquêtes confirment
qu'il s'agit bel et bien de camp de
détention extrajudiciaire
ça révèle une toute autre réalité que ce
que la chine veut nous faire croire ça
n'a rien de ce que peut représenter une
école dans lesquels on est libre d'être
les directives des hauts dirigeants ils
sont clairs poste de police aux entrées
tour de guet dortoir verrouillé à double
tour dans lesquels des caméras de
surveillance doivent balayer les
moindres recoins et surtout empêcher les
internés de s'évader
les documents précisent que
l'internement doit durer au minimum un
an
les internes et doivent subir un
endoctrinement quotidien effectué des
travaux manuels
ils ne sont libérés que s'ils ont
démontré avoir abandonné l'islam au
profit du parti communiste
c'est un lavage de cerveau très corrosif
et si vous ne changez pas on vous punit
dit ce chercheur allemand
il estime que jusqu'à un million huit
cent mille huit bourg ont été internés
près de 20 % de leur population
yu l'ambassadeur de chine à londres ni
la véracité des documents mais leur
authenticité a été confirmée par de
nombreux experts et leur contenu
corroboré par des témoignages d'ex
détenus en exil qui rapporte même
l'emploi de la torture aux tab
tous les soirs nous pouvions entendre
des gens crier c'était comme si on les
torture est un peu plus faire silence
sur ce qui se passe donc il faut prendre
des mesures beaucoup plus importante
c'est beaucoup plus direct
cette fuite de secrets d'état est
problématique pour la chine et pour son
image à l'étranger au canada des membres
de la communauté ouïghoure exhorte
ottawa a imposé des sanctions contre les
hauts dirigeants chinois responsables
ici fait le regza lac radio canada
vancouver